- You are going to learn how to get
right to the point in a conversation.
And today we're here with Chris Fenning.
He's the author of the
book, "The First Minute:
"How to Start Conversations
That Get Results."
Thanks for being with us today, Chris.
- Hi, Alex, it's great to be here.
- If you'd like to connect with Chris,
you can look at his website,
his LinkedIn profile,
of course, I'll link
to his book on Amazon,
and you can check out his
YouTube page, as well.
I'll put links to all of those things
in the description below the video.
So Chris, one of the most
common questions I get is, Alex,
when you're out in the
work world consulting,
what's the biggest communication problem
that you hear about?
And I would say the number
one complaint I hear about is
that people say, the people around me
are really long-winded.
So what's your perspective
on that complaint?
- I think that is, yeah,
one of the highest,
if not the highest issues
that I see, as well.
What I find interesting
about it is it's always
other people who are long-winded.
Ask a room full of people
if they know someone
who struggles to get to the point,
they're all going to nod and say yes.
Ask those same people if they
are the person who struggles
to get to the point,
oh no, no, it's not me,
it's always other people who
have that particular challenge.
- That's right, I find that one
of the biggest misunderstandings
about communication
is that people who can just talk a lot
think they're good communicators,
but it's almost exactly the opposite.
So today what we're going
to do is learn how to get
right to the point in a
way that will get results.
And we're going to do this
by framing the conversation,
which Chris talks about in his book,
and we're gonna talk
about three key questions
that'll help us frame the
conversation the right way.
Right when we start a conversation,
people are often asking themselves,
what are you talking about?
So Chris, why does this happen
and what can we do about
it to answer that question?
- We've all been there
a minute or two minutes
into a conversation and
we're still thinking,
what are you talking about?
What is this, what does it relate to?
And the reason this happens
is the person who's speaking
hasn't defined the context
for the conversation.
You don't know whether they're
talking about a meeting
next week, or a client problem,
or something that just was a funny story.
When we don't provide context,
the people we're talking
to struggle to focus
and they're spending their
time trying to work out
what is it we're actually talking about.
The great thing is context
is easy to provide.
In just three or five words,
you can tell the person you're talking to.
what you're talking about.
Something like, I have an
update on next week's meeting,
or I'd like to talk to you
about the Jefferson account,
or can I talk to you
about Robin's pay rise?
Those few words tell you,
I could say, hey, Alex,
I wanna talk to you about
our meeting next week.
You now know everything else I'm going
to say is about the meeting next week
and it's not about lunch, or
reports, or anything else.
- That's why we buy a book, right?
We see a title like yours
and we say, oh, the first minute,
I need to know about that,
I know what this book is about now.
And if we are only
thinking that in our heads
but never verbalize that until
later in the conversation,
that's a really demanding
way to start a conversation
to make them guess what
it is we're talking about.
So you want to be really
upfront about that.
It takes a little reflection
before you start the conversation,
but it's pretty easy to get to.
And I noticed the samples that
you used were very concise.
It's just one short little sentence
that does a lot of heavy lifting.
So let's say we tell them
what we're talking about.
The second question that most
listeners ask themselves is,
why are you talking to me
about this specifically?
So why do people always ask
themselves this question
and what can we do to
make sure we don't leave
that question unanswered?
- Yes, this is the situation
where someone has come up
to you and you understand
what the topic is,
you know the context,
but they've been talking
for a few minutes,
you have no idea whether
you're being asked a question,
is this just them venting
about a situation,
do you have to take an action?
And the reason we think those things
and we have that question of
why are you talking to me,
why are you telling me this,
it's because the person speaking
hasn't made the intent clear.
Now, there's some science behind this
in the way our short-term memories work,
that until our brain knows what to do
with a piece of information,
it struggles to process it
because different parts of
our brain work on listening
to a funny story or answering a question.
And until we know the intent,
until we know the purpose
for that conversation, our
brains are stuck in a loop
saying, why are you telling
me this, what do I do with it,
what do I do with it,
what do I do with it?
And that's why we get
stuck in that question of,
well, why are you talking to me?
Now, the easy way to avoid this is
after providing context, you
literally tell the other person
what you want them to do
with the information you're giving them.
For example, can I talk to
you about next week's meeting?
I need your help to identify
the people to bring.
Or I want you to talk to you
about this particular client's account,
I need your help approving a refund.
So we've got, I need your
help, I want your input.
Heads up, something is about to happen.
These short phrases that tell
the other person what to do
make the intent really clear
and they will focus on everything
else that you have to say.
- Excellent examples.
So we all ask this question
whether we're watching
a presentation, we're in a group meeting,
one-on-one conversation,
we all ask some version
of Why are you telling me this?
So I have this guy I
know, I wouldn't call him
a close friend, but I know him,
and he frequently will interrupt you
in the middle of a conversation.
And he asks a little bit rough,
he'll say, what's this got to do with me?
And I would not imitate his
style, but he is being honest.
He doesn't understand why you're talking
to him about this in particular.
And I think everybody asks
some version of that question,
hopefully a little more politely.
But they're always wondering,
what do I have to do
with this information?
Why are you talking to me about it?
How can I take action?
Maybe they're even asking, how can I help?
But unless you tell them that directly,
they're still going to wonder.
So that brings us to the third question,
and that is, you've
already created context,
you've already signaled intention,
and the last part is they're
asking, what's your point?
What is the point of this conversation?
So tell us how we can get to that point
in the conversation really clearly.
- Oh yes, clearly and quickly.
There is very little that's
more frustrating at work
than listening to somebody
go on and on and on
and thinking, what is your point?
I understand what you want
from me, but what's the point?
And that is caused by missing a headline
from the start of your message.
One of the best ways to imagine this
or to to experience this
outside of a conversation
is pick up a magazine, or newspaper,
or look at an article online
and start reading from paragraph seven.
How long will it take you to work out
what the article is about?
You could even read the entire thing
from paragraph seven onwards
and still not be quite sure
what the overall article or message is.
Compare that to starting with a title
and a really clear first
line in the article.
If that's there and that's
what you've read first,
everything else after that
makes a lot more sense.
If that's true in magazines,
it's true in conversation.
When you start talking to someone,
don't start on paragraph seven.
Don't start in the detail.
Don't start with backstory or evidence.
Start with a headline,
say this is the thing
I want to talk to you about.
So we've already given
some examples of this.
I snuck them in a little earlier.
So one example would be,
for context, I'd like
to talk about the Jefferson's account.
The intent is I need your help.
And the key message is,
I would like your help
with approving a refund
because we've had some late deliveries.
So the key message is
we need to refund them
or we Want to refund them because
we've had late deliveries.
There's a lot more in that conversation
about why are they late and
what have we done about it,
how much is the refund, but
the person you're talking to
will know and understand
what that conversation
is going to be about
because it's been framed,
they've got the context,
they've got that intent,
and that key message,
the headline, has set up
the rest of the conversation
really clearly for them.
- I love it, excellent examples.
So in three concise
sentences, you have created
an effective and productive foundation
for the rest of the conversation.
If you skip these three
sentences, they're gonna be trying
to answer these questions for themselves,
they're gonna be jumping to conclusions,
and it's going to create a very demanding
and confusing conversation
until you answer these.
So start on the right foot,
answer these three
questions in this order,
and you're off to the races.
Now, in terms of next steps,
we have these three tips.
What can people do with these
three tips moving forward?
- It's a simple method.
As with a lot of simple
methods, the difficulty is
how do you apply it and
apply it consistently?
And one thing that we can
all do is if we are about
to have a conversation with
someone, take 30 seconds
and just write down, you
could do this mentally,
but writing it down helps,
just jot down the answers
to those three questions.
Either say, my context is
this, my intent is this,
and the key message is that,
or you can answer the question
of, what is this about,
why am I talking to them,
and what's the point?
And a single sentence,
three to five words for each
of them is enough to really
set up that conversation.
So take that moment to prepare
before any important conversation,
and it will really, really help.
- Wonderful, thank you so
much, Chris, for being here.
I just wanna remind viewers,
you can check out Chris's book on Amazon.
There are links to his
LinkedIn, his website,
and his YouTube channel in the
description below the video.
He's got amazing and helpful
content just like this.
Thanks for being here with us, Chris.
- Thank you, Alex, it's been a pleasure.